all right so now i'm going to do the
analysis of this op-amp configuration
again and i'm going to do it using the
idea of a virtual ground
and the idea of a virtual ground
actually makes really short work of
analyzing a circuit like this
to review the virtual ground idea it
says if this voltage here if v out
is in a reasonable range between the
power supplies of of its op amp
and remember the power supplies are not
shown here but they're connected up to
the op amp so this is a number that's
sort of like one hand of volts you know
or two hands of volts between between
zero and plus or minus 10 volts
something like that and the gain of this
op amp is
huge it's just gigantic it's up in the
hundreds of thousands or millions
and so whenever there's a normal finite
size voltage here it means the voltage
here is about zero it's very close to
zero it's down in the very small micro
volts
and the idea of a virtual ground says
that if this node here is at zero volts
which we've drawn it grounded so it's at
zero volts that means that this minus
terminal is going to be also held at
zero volts very close to zero volts and
that makes this virtually a ground or a
virtual ground
another way to write this is to say that
that v plus is approximately equal to v
minus
now my professor who taught me this had
a little symbol for it what he did was
he drew it like this
so you can sketch that
on your schematics just a little symbol
there and that symbol will help remind
you that those those two nodes are at
the same voltage
okay so let's do the analysis again we
had this was r1 and this is r2
and we have a current flowing here
called i
and we can write an expression for i so
the voltage on this side
the voltage on this side of the resistor
is v in and the voltage on this side of
the resistor is
it's zero volts it's zero volts
because we have a virtual ground here so
we know the voltage on both sides so i
can say right away i
equals the voltage difference
v in minus zero so just v in
divided by
r one
so we have an expression for i
now as you remember the thing we also
know about op amps is that this current
is zero here
there's there's no current going into
the input of an ideal op amp a real
op-amp there'll be a really tiny tiny
current there
for our purposes right now we can treat
this as a zero current going in here so
what does that mean that means that i
goes through r2
so let's write an expression for i going
through r2 and we need to know the
voltage on each side of r2 well this
side
this is v naught or v out
this side is v out and this side again
we get to use the zero
so i
through r 2
equals
let's get the sign right so the
current's going in this way so this is
the positive this is the relatively
positive side and this is the negative
side
so i is 0
minus v out
divided by r2
all right
now let's set these two currents equal
to each other so that means that vn
over r1
equals minus v out
over r2
and what we want is an expression that
tells us what v out is in terms of v n
so v out
equals
v n
times let's see
r two goes on top
r one goes on the bottom
and there's a minus sign
and we did it and that's the expression
for v out in terms of v in for the
inverting op-amp configuration now by
using the virtual ground idea the
analysis became really simple it's
basically one two three steps to get to
the answer compare that to the algebra
that we did in the previous video when
we did this from first principles
so that's an example of applying the
virtual ground idea to analyze an op-amp
circuit
let's i'll do one more real quick
so here's a different op-amp
configuration we haven't seen this one
before
first thing to notice
first thing to notice is that now plus
is on top always take a peek at your op
amp to see which terminal is on top we
have v in here as usual
and here's v out
and again what we want to do is find out
what's v out in terms of v in
now this circuit has has no resistors in
it
okay that's that's all right
we'll figure out what's going on here
okay let's apply the idea of virtual
ground so i'm going to make my little
virtual ground symbol here
like that that reminds me that these two
terminals are the same voltage if we're
doing the right thing
so let's figure out what v out is
v out equals this terminal here and this
one is pretty much equal to this one and
what's this one this is v out v or sorry
v in
so
boom
we just did it in one step that's the
answer
this configuration is called a buffer
or it's also called a
unity gain
buffer
this is just a long way to say the gain
is one
so that's an example of a unity gain
buffer and we use the virtual ground
idea to
analyze it almost instantly